thank you
[Music]
the past few years have been full of
action-packed fights and in this video
I'll showcase some of my favorite ones
let's do this season by season so strap
yourselves in and let's get going with
the show
there it is
with winter 2020 we have some Legacy
franchises making their Mark well I'm
not sure that fgo counts as a legacy
franchise as much since I'm using the
term with the context of the fake
universe as a whole it did give us one
of the best Grand finale's we could ever
hope for Babylonia has been a
consistently great adaptation many
things considered and the final battle
wraps things up with a battle of Epic
Proportions seeing all those Noble
phantasms in the tension-filled battle
against Thea month is a thing of beauty
it's also an Extended sequence that
takes place across multiple episodes but
time just flew by watching them oh and
the other Legacy series I'm talking
about Royal gun railgun is generally
seen as the best anime in the toaru
universe and with how index 3 turned out
not too long ago from railgun T that
much is obvious The Showdown against
misaka at the climax of the first half
is also a joy to watch it's not quite as
epic as the Tiamat battle but it does
get the job done really well and as a
bonus does a great job in playing in
developing the relationship between
misaka and Thoma oh and we get to see
gun heart show off his power for the
first time ever too
the spring 2020 we take to the world of
Shonen as it was endeavor's moment of
Glory my hero Academia fans certainly a
fond memories of this as Endeavor takes
on hurt in one of the best battles we
got looking at the franchise as a whole
while fans may not have as much
emotional attachment to Endeavor
compared to all might this fight seemed
to be the turning point in the
perception of him it's all sorts of
awesome and it's here that we first got
to see what a cool hero Endeavor really
is in terms of Animation however few can
match what we got from Oya and the Mast
outcasts it's a fight that I've often
discussed on this channel and it's not
quite as popular actually due to being
in a very Niche anime so just take a
look at the clip for yourself and see
how quick how fluid and how well
animated everything is it's truly one of
the best hand-to-hand fights in anime of
all time before we end the season how
about giving some love to the fight that
put gleip near on the map should we
cheat versus hikabat turned a lot of
heads that time and for good reason too
who knew that the epic fight animation
and the gripping sequences in this
battle was only a preview of the other
awesome things the anime would give us
foreign
had a lot of great sequels but if we're
looking at fights especially in the
aspect of crisp animation there's no
better place to go than China it's in
this season where we've got a double
header from both fog Hill and white cat
Legend there's not much I'd like to say
here that I haven't already said before
but I will let the clips do the talking
Chinese anime is quickly catching up in
terms of production quality that much is
undeniable I mean I'm still not
convinced that they can break into the
mainstream but who knows what will
happen in the next decade or so it's a
non-zero possibility after all right the
season was also known at the time for
God of high school while the actual
adaptation may leave a lot to be desired
due to how they adapted the story at the
Breakneck speed they did there's no
doubt that the fights are top-notch Jin
had a lot of crazy awesome encounters
there but for the sake of this video I'd
like to give the fight against jagal
some love for other honorable mentions
we have the Shonen double header of
Zorro versus killer as well as Benny
Maru versus holy souls Shadows we also
have Kirito versus Gabrielle which I
really enjoyed both as a fan of Sao and
a guy who's a sucker for Spirit Bomb
like Fighters fight hell put a
punctuation on what magically seem like
the end of the storied franchise
fall 2020 saw the rise of the next big
thing in shonem Jiu Jitsu Kaizen and it
didn't waste much time getting its feet
on the gas bang a fight after Banger
fight and his first half alone brought a
stuff like Yuji and nanami vs mahito
captains also clashed in Black Clover
and while it's only a preview of the
awesomeness that's about to come it
feels so good seeing everyone go all out
a true heavyweight Showdown for Black
Clover fans to remember new team Seven's
not going to let themselves be outshined
however and their fight with deeper was
likewise awesome I really love that it's
a team effort in that one meanwhile Bell
and asterius added more in their storied
rivalry solidifying their status as
pretty much equals in the field and if
you want something so amazing coming
from a show that slipped under
everyone's radar executioner versus
brawler from akodama Drive could be your
jam
what's up
we then move on to the year 2021 where
the New Year comes New Beginnings here
Jiu Jitsu Kaizen kept up with a huge
momentum it built up from the previous
year giving us what I consider its best
fight Yuji and Toto vs Hanami is nothing
short of insane the animation is good
the emotional Stakes are good the actual
flow of the battle is good as well and
while all eyes are on Jiu-Jitsu Kaizen
at this time I feel this right to once
again bridge to Black Clover which gave
us the Epic Asta and Yami vs Dante fight
the Black Clover anime was on its last
legs at this time but it sure is going
out with a blaze of glory and let's not
forget that this is the season that
kick-started the aot final and while
things have changed a lot for Attack on
Titan over the years one thing hasn't
and it's the ever-present exciting
battles that the show has to offer Aaron
versus Warhammer Titan is truly a sight
to see to finish off it may not be the
flashiest fight the series has had but I
personally have a soft spot for ram
versus Roswell the way that episode
ended was just excellent and it gave
some much needed depth to two of
re-zero's less prominent characters
spring 2021 continues to train kind of
awesome fights with eye-popping
animation re-zero's second season may
have ended his run but Tempe naganski
kept his fingerprints on the anime
industry with Vivi while not exactly a
fight-centric show in my opinion Vivi
does a great job of making it look so
just take a look at how much effort they
put on this Vivi and Hugo fight and
speaking of sci-fi titles that have
rather complex themes I bring you 86.
it's a show that's all about ethics
politics and the like but I have no
doubt that the final confrontation
between Shin and Rey had you in tears
especially when the musical Masterpiece
Avid hit during the closing moments in
terms of pure hype however this season's
best fight goes to Naruto and Sasuke vs
jigim Naruto fans have been waiting for
this moment since forever and it hits a
lot harder to see both Naruto and Sasuke
teaming up again after so long and my
joke that boruto triples in quality when
these Legacy characters fight still
holds true now Naruto wasn't quite done
yet because Summer 2021 is when we got
this legendary fight versus ishigi this
is a fight that Naruto fans should never
miss out on we got treated to Barry on
mode and an emotional farewell to one of
the most prominent and important
characters in the series all in our
previous Heroes bid for Redemption
there's also some other good stuff
coming from the world of Shonen around
this time villain versus villain battles
are fun especially when there's a lot of
hype surrounding the two and their power
levels shigaraki and redestro made sure
to hammer that point down to talk about
honorable mentions however we move on to
Dragon maid yes indeed Dragon maid had
that toru vs Elma fight that gave the
show a sudden but welcome Edge it feels
so cool seeing the sheer destruction and
intensity in a series this generally
light-hearted and comedic oh and while
detective is already dead has garnered
quite the polarizing reception I think
everyone can agree that the first
episode's fight sequence on the plane is
the show's High Point siesta's clash
with bat is a thing of beauty
ah
full 2021 was a season of big hits too
way more stack than some I'd say after
all it's got a new Demon Slayer season
and those people who missed the movie
got treated to another take on rain Goku
versus akaza it's all throughout an epic
fight even with Demon Slayer standards
and it's the attraction the moviegoers
look for when they helped Infinity train
break all those records left and right
can I just comment on how lucky TV anime
viewers are for getting to experience
this fight too granted I think it just
looks way better on a big screen but
still musoku tensei also had one of its
most gripping fights in the form of dead
end versus allstead by all means it's a
swash match but the battle did such a
great job of evoking emotions in viewers
the acting and the subsequent emotional
Stakes created by the fight there's
nothing like this in ushoku tensei up
until that point it's truly a notable
sequence now let's not forget one of the
biggest sleeper hits of the Year ranking
of Kings it's so overlooked but turned
out to be one of the best shows to come
out that year and as for its fight there
are a lot of great examples but I'm
gonna go ahead and give dorsche vs Hans
some love but there are other contenders
that I wouldn't mind putting as its best
battle
get it
while Jiu Jitsu Kaizen opened the
previous year with an even better
showing thanks to its momentum its demon
slayer's turn this time round the whole
climax of The Entertainment District Arc
is something that I've shown much love
for on this channel and how could I not
it's supposedly something very long but
it never felt that way watching it due
to how well it separates the long
battles into multiple segments or giving
our characters different times to shine
the astounding animation qualities are
given but narratively in pacing wise
team tengen versus the two upper moons
also got the job done Picasso versus the
jaegeris is also something that we can
take note of it's not too often that you
get human versus human clashes in Attack
on Titan especially this early on when
they happen the results are often good
on another note Ali fioretta certainly
stepped up its game for the second
season Hajime vs neoint was a struggle
for the protagonist the first one in a
while it's one of the more engaging
battles the series had in its two
seasons and in the same vein as the
dragon made example a while ago we have
a light-hearted series making a 180 turn
in terms of drama and intensity with
Princess connect second C season so much
that the lead-up to Pickering versus
Kaiser Insight basically the last three
or so episodes of the show had me
staying up late at night waiting for Raw
spoilers and screenshots now that's how
invested I was in this finale right
before we move on how about hitting that
like button if you like what you've been
seeing so far likes and interactions
make for some good algorithm and it
helps the video do better and that way I
can also know that you love these kinds
of videos and we'll make more of them
ah
if you're looking for something that
delivers on the hype on the build up on
the story look no further than my pick
for spring 2022 worst generation versus
kaido and big mom for so many years so
many seasons it's been building up to
this showdown of Epic Proportions the
great kaido and big mom have formed an
Unholy Alliance and it would take the
strongest opponents to defeat them turns
out Luffy and the worst Generations are
more than up to the task giving us
episode after episode of Goosebump
inducing action sequences dialogue and
drama short one piece is nowhere near
over but this really had that big fight
feel that makes it look very fitting for
a Show's Grand Finale but I also want to
give some knee shits a bit of Shine for
this year bubble didn't exactly blow the
world away but that uttar vs Undertaker
sequence was a good example of cinematic
master class in terms of how camera
Direction drives up immersion there's
also finai versus Kubo a gem from
Vampire in the garden
thank you
summer 2022 also brought us some
underrated hits at the Forefront of it
was summertime render for such a good
show it gets so little traction a
complete Journey that's full of Mastery
and surprises not to mention some Banger
action scenes that can give Shonen hits
a run for their money I love the final
battle to death but I think that the
best one amongst the fights would be
humans vs shadows in the school a
complete team effort that showcased the
power and resilience of humanity in
spite of physically being outmatched
licorice recore on the other hand took
the anime World by storm seemingly out
of nowhere but the show just works and
while the main attraction for me is the
characters and how alive they are pun
intended thanks to its dialogue it's no
slouch in fights the final which is Otto
faces off against majima is still
something I re-watch when I'm in the
mood for it and before leaving this
season I'd like to give a shout out to
Team Ruby versus nightmare Blake
foreign
if you thought that that's not enough
epic battles for summer four has you
covered in a big way Blockbuster bleach
made us return to much fanfare and a lot
of it has to do with the fight's an
overall mood of the Season making the
whole thing feel cinematic and there's
no better example of that than Yamamoto
versus yuha a high battle Breaking All
the expectations it helps set the tone
as to what kind of season Thousand-Year
blood War will be for Bleach meanwhile
we've got the whole league of villains
thing done for my hero Academia at this
point in time it's time for the new and
improved shigaraki to show everyone what
he's made of a true Terra incarnate this
season this fight against everyone is
one of the best fights my hero Academia
has put out in the post all might ERA
this season also Mark the debut of one
of the most talked about action series
chainsaw man for the most part chainsaw
man has lived up to the expectations and
its adaptations of its fights really
brought in the much requested impact on
violence denji vs Katana man is my
highlight for the show so far with New
Beginnings come heartbreaking farewells
yet you know what I'm talking about are
you poochie versus everyone in Jojo and
dimple versus psycho helmet are awesome
fights in their own right
[Music]
foreign
familiar territory now isn't it how did
last season hold up for you well for me
it felt really good seeing boruto
finally get his shine in a Solo fight
against gamaki it feels like a coming
out party for our protagonist who's been
overshadowed by a lot of fellow
characters in his own series it seems
It's time we get to see some awesome
solo boruto acting and 2023 gave us just
that I also quite like the new Trigun it
doesn't feel as magical as the original
but the knives vs Vash fight was
something to take note of speaking of
things that aren't as hype but still
manage to hold out well in terms of
quality we've got lady nargant versus
Deku lady nargar doesn't carry as much
of a presence of shigaraki but this
fight against Deku really sold you on
the idea of her as an awesome character
so while going from shigaraki's Rampage
to this might seem like a downgrade the
fight itself slams that idea shut
kaido's also still not dumb I do think
the fight involving the worst generation
has a lot more highlight potential to it
this battle against Luffy and Yamato is
likewise lit it's the ultimate tag team
that nokaido down a Peg and for the
cemented Yamato is a major fan favorite
amongst the key characters in one piece
now at the time of writing spring 2023
isn't done yet and I'm going to make a
separate video just for it soon
oh so how's that for a three-year recap
these three years have shown us some
excellence in the world of anime fights
and I can't wait to see more okay so
leave this down in the comments which
fights are your favorite from the past
three years and which upcoming shows are
you seeing some potential in I do hope
to hear your thoughts both here and on
videotube's many social media channels
thanks for watching the video hope you
enjoyed it and I'll see you in the next
one